[Música]
en tranquilidad y con baja participación
fueron realizadas las elecciones
parlamentarias en venezuela 20 millones
de ciudadanos fueron llamados a
participar en unos cuestionados comicios
que no cuentan con la participación de
partidos de la oposición y son
rechazados por diferentes sectores
políticos por falta de garantías tenemos
reportes desde la ciudad de caracas
y estos comicios legislativos en
venezuela cuenta cuentan con un récord
de aspirantes 14.400 candidatos intentan
obtener uno de los doscientos setenta y
siete escaños que conforman la asamblea
nacional un órgano político que será
elegido en unos comicios que no cuentan
con reconocimiento de la comunidad
internacional
a sus 80 años y víctimas de cáncer de
pulmón falleció el ex presidente de
uruguay tabaré vázquez quien se
convirtió en el primer mandatario de
izquierda en gobernar ese país
suramericano el gobierno uruguayo
decretó tres días de luto nacional y
ordenó que las banderas ondeen a media
asta
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález estamos en vivo desde nuestros
estudios en bogotá en colombia a esta
hora avanza el conteo de los votos en
las elecciones parlamentarias de
venezuela unos comicios que no cuentan
con el reconocimiento de la comunidad
internacional y en los que no
participaron los partidos de la
oposición 20 millones de ciudadanos
fueron convocados pero la baja
participación fue la protagonista de
esta jornada que también fue pacífica en
total 14 mil 400 candidatos buscan
adjudicarse uno de los 277 escaños que
conforman esta asamblea nacional que es
precedida por juan guaidó quien también
es el presidente de venezuela reconocido
por 50 países alrededor del mundo
vamos a conocer más detalles con
herminia fernández en la ciudad de
caracas nuestra corresponsal permanente
allí en la capital venezolana
herminia muy buenas noches y cuáles son
las novedades a esta hora está avanzando
el conteo de los votos
así santiago buenas noches puede ser
todo el país está la expectativa de los
resultados de estas elecciones debieran
haber salido en tiempo récord porque se
supone que no hubo mucha asistencia sin
embargo no hay ninguna información de
parte del consejo nacional electoral no
hay ningún dato de transmisión hasta
este momento no hay ningún dato de que a
qué hora puede darse a conocer cuántas y
cuántos diputados del partido socialista
unido de venezuela habré habrían ganado
y cuántos de esta oposición de la que no
participaban waldo y sus aliados también
ganarían algunos asientos en las urnas
finalmente cerraron casi a las 8 de la
noche hace un par de horas y se veía en
la televisión pública a la gente e
intentando agotar hasta esta hora porque
el partido socialista unido de venezuela
hizo un llamado a sus electores a última
hora al final de la tarde a las 6 de la
tarde para que quienes no habían acudido
lo hicieran
herminia vale la pena decir que el cdn y
las autoridades de venezuela han
indicado que su sistema electoral es uno
de los más modernos y rápidos del mundo
cuenta con un voto electrónico pero
seguimos a la espera entonces de algún
resultado parcial de este conteo hace
unos minutos también habló juan guaidó
que es el presidente de la asamblea
nacional y también como lo decíamos
presidente reconocido por 50 países
alrededor del mundo que dijo waldo
y why do transmitió un comunicado pre
grabado en las redes sociales donde
bueno decía un poco lo que fue
repitiendo a lo largo de esta semana
pasada y lo que repitió durante hoy
durante las redes sociales señalaba que
los estos comicios ya tienen un
resultado que el gobierno de nicolás
maduro lo tiene listo supuestamente solo
están esperando para mostrarlos también
señalaba que se contó que se consumó lo
que él llama el fraude y que madurara ha
perdido respaldo popular por otra parte
también insistió en que hay que salvar a
venezuela y que hizo y me uní a culpa
diciendo que la oposición está obligada
a mantenerse de pie a rectificar ya
seguir adelante gracias al minia por
este reporte desde la ciudad de caracas
y seguimos atentos a los resultados que
puedan arrojar allí las autoridades en
venezuela vamos a analizar este tema con
alex gonzález ella es directora de la
cátedra libre de democracia y elecciones
de la universidad central de venezuela
está en
de caracas también en la capital
venezolana muy buenas noches señora
gonzález y estas son unas elecciones
particulares porque no cuentan con el
total del espectro político que hay en
venezuela entonces esto claramente ya de
entrada dice que es lejos de ser unas
elecciones democráticas esto es un golpe
para el sistema político venezolano que
ya viene siendo golpeado a lo largo de
estos años y esto se vería reflejado
también en esa baja participación
ciudadana como analiza usted la
situación
muy buenas noches muchas gracias por la
invitación y ciertamente este proceso
parlamentario no será un proceso más que
se pueda estudiar o cualquier creo
contra la integridad electoral si no
quedara dejara registro de cómo un país
que tuvo una sólida democracia pues se
desmorona a través de los propios
métodos que la democracia trae cómo son
los procesos electorales un proceso
donde estuvo signado por la
judicialización de los partidos eso se
le quitaron la junta directiva a los
partidos que vencieron al oficialismo en
el 2015 esto agrava la situación y
quizás explique la baja participación
que se percibió en los diferentes
centros de votación por supuesto con
toda seguridad lo que tiene que ver con
la falta de pluralidad con la falta
falta de participación del ciudadano en
la política serán dos variables que van
a disminuir sensiblemente
o factores democráticos o valores
democrático venezolano es sumamente el k
o lo que está ocurriendo señora gonzález
gracias por este análisis para la
audiencia de francés 24 gracias por
estar con nosotros en otros temas
destacados de la jornada falleció a los
80 años víctima de cáncer de pulmón el
ex presidente de la república oriental
del uruguay tabaré vázquez quien fuera
el líder del partido frente amplio
vázquez un destacado político en su país
era también médico oncólogo de profesión
el gobierno decretó allí tres días de
luto nacional le ordenó que todas las
banderas ondeen a media asta
previamente conversamos con karina da al
más la corresponsal de france 24 en la
ciudad de montevideo la capital uruguaya
y nos dio más detalles de la jornada su
familia decidió realizar los servicios
fúnebres a nivel privado les exhortó a
la población a seguir los mismos por los
medios de comunicación para evitar la
expansión de la pandemia del cobi 19 en
el país sin embargo aunque miles
y apoyaron esta medida otros tantos
miles dieron su último adiós en las
calles al ex presidente tabaré vázquez
varios mandatarios internacionales de
diferentes orientaciones políticas lo
destacaron como un gran estadista
uruguay vive en estos momentos tres días
de duelo nacional y en otros temas la
unión europea y el reino unido- hacen
los últimos esfuerzos posibles para
concretar un acuerdo post over exit que
está estancado por discrepancias en
cuanto al equilibrio de las relaciones
londres bruselas la gobernanza y también
los temas de pesca los jefes
negociadores se reanudarán las
conversaciones en bruselas el lunes para
alcanzar puntos en común las partes
tienen hasta el 31 de diciembre del 2020
para llegar a un acuerdo y evitar el
llamado pre éxito lo que implicaría la
imposición de aranceles entre las dos
regiones entre otras medidas
y más de 300 personas fueron detenidas
este domingo en minsk a la capital de
belarús en una masiva manifestación
ciudadana contra el gobierno del
presidente alexander lukashenko se trata
del décimo octavo domingo consecutivo
que tienen lugar estas protestas contra
el presidente de ese país quien afirma
haber ganado de manera abrumadora en las
elecciones presidenciales del pasado
agosto en unos comicios señalados de
fraude por parte de los partidos de
oposición y los partidos independientes
y también este lunes 17 millones de
ghaneses irán a las urnas para elegir al
nuevo presidente de ese país africano es
la tercera vez que los dos favoritos el
actual mandatario akufo addo y el ex
presidente líder de la oposición john
dramani mahama se enfrentan en unos
comicios presidenciales el actual
mandatario busca mantenerse en la silla
presidencial por segundo periodo de
manera consecutiva mahatma indicó que de
no triunfar en los comicios no va a
reconocer los resultados y acusar a de
fraude a la comisión electoral central
de ghana
y para el cierre les contamos que una
cápsula japonesa con las primeras
muestras del subsuelo de un asteroide
cruzó ya la atmósfera terrestre y
aterrizó de manera exitosa en una zona
remota en australia de esta manera
completó una misión para obtener
indicios sobre el origen del sistema
solar y de la vida del planeta tierra la
sonda espacial hayabusa 2 liberó una
pequeña cápsula que regreso a nuestro
planeta con las muestras que fueron
tomadas en este asteroide que estaba muy
distante de nuestro planeta en el
espacio con estas imágenes finalizamos
este informativo en france 24 buenas
noches
[Música]